[Music]
ah
yes the beasting king in the rat king
welcome to cte behind the scenes
today well you you got some ct that's
sure
dude i was born with a couple of
different things low oxygen
um low iq what else carbon monoxide
there was a fire a little bit of the
down
uh get that down ass oh dude you got
that dss
you mean downs yeah they had a bunch of
geese outside in the brain brain
are we talking about what's up there was
a bunch of geese outside when i was born
is that what you're talking about when
you say downs
yeah yeah and i beat down syndrome and a
lot of people know that and others
haven't
it's a survivor story i know that bro oh
i'll be back for you
those people that haven't made it i'll
be back for you
uh new studio bro yeah new studio look
at this
same wall piece i'm old sign brand new
studio
looking like a real beehive up in here
bro yeah man
it uh and you know i catch that free
buzz off that paint
yeah me too oh yeah you got problems you
tell your uh
parole officer about this i don't have a
parole officer
you don't i think you're a therapist a
pro officer uh
one of those service dogs a service
peacock
and a reptile that keeps you calm on
planes
it's a therapist okay you say a
therapist like it's a drink you get
from there bro you're not from this the
therapist right there
you didn't grow up
you ain't ready for that did i do that
you don't know [ __ ] about it
i love mystical and uh what was the
question oh it looks like charlie brown
painted our set huh oh definitely got
that charlie brown sweater oh it really
does i mean think about that
um what were you talking about uh i was
talking about you have a service dog
um i don't know bro i don't know
i'm nervous go to edmonton you ever been
there or it's freezing
oh dude i one time i was at a um
you know i was at a group event down in
florida i was on a cruise ship
you know vessel and we parked at the end
of it and i got off got into a plane
right i've been drinking and partying
all weekend
you were there with your friends you
weren't working you were just oh yeah i
was there with my friends having fun
older people
yeah all types of all-age people even
some kid even tried to tickle me in the
hot tub one time and it caused quite a
sign
right r kelly uh i didn't know him he
chose to do it
okay but anyway what happened was i got
on a plane man just hung over i lay down
i crashed right it's like
78 degrees when i got on the airplane in
fort lauderdale
i get off in edmonton dude it's negative
37 degrees are you still dressed like
weekend at bernie's dude the person next
to me
died whenever we let this just frozen
they were completely frozen
they were completely [ __ ] frozen dude
i get off people or yeah there's just
frozen people everywhere why it's so
goddamn cold up
just like frozen children it's like
asking stuff for their mom
frozen dudes like that yeah just chill
dude i remember walking to the grocery
some i had just like going like
i was dressed like you know like um ben
selleck or something in a magnum pi you
know
okay um tom selleck thomas
thomas sell it and the um and some guy
pulled over he's like you're gonna die
man
rap made a bunch of wolves bro what were
you thinking
i was thinking how long ago was that
trying to get a snack trying to grab
some oatmeal or something
um this was probably about seven years
ago oh a hot minute ago dude i got food
poisoning after that
oh damn you're making me scared to go to
edmonton very scary dude i would not eat
anything up there bring your own food
really and don't drink the water
dude i wouldn't drink anything no i said
[Music]
bro there's people yeah it's very
alarming man it could be very alarming
but a lot of nice people man i'm sure
you have a good time
yeah hopefully bro all right let's get
into this let's get into this what we've
got this week
thanks to all the fans for the
submissions you guys uh again you guys
make this show they've been great
they've been hilarious
some of them been pretty subject but
some of them have been great some get
weird yeah i was just trying to be
positive dude i know you were yeah
thanks
definitely some weird ones but uh for
the most part it was it was hard to pick
uh
only four or five uh let's start with
the bay club
the first one is from travis hart
oh wow travis heart the rapper yeah slap
on your headphones if you can real quick
just to hear it
okay this dude's a rapper no no i'm
thinking about somebody else are you
thinking of travis scott
what's this guy's name travis hart very
similar very easy to mess up
how's it going theo and brendan my name
is travis i'm from great falls montana
i have a debate club topic for you guys
i am a big fan of music
my two favorite genres are traditional
country and rap so i want to know debate
club
rap music versus country music but good
rap music versus good country music not
like
little pump versus florida georgia line
horseshit notorious b.i.g versus george
straight so debate club
rap music versus country music i
appreciate you guys yeah oh wow
florida georgia line is probably one of
the top 60 or 70 bands of all time
you're right don't [ __ ] touch me bro
i'm serious dude i love florida georgia
live
not touch me hurry i don't i'm sorry man
don't touch me though but that florida
georgia line scout
any man of mine who sang that song uh
better
stomp stomp that lady stomp stomp yeah
should i ask you shania twain
yeah we're talking good [ __ ] well let's
be honest uh
country music is basically white rap
you know the words rhyme alcohol
yep there's booze chicks there's chicks
they just don't refer to them as hoes
yeah they don't call them
they have [ __ ] but they're actual
dogs yes yeah in the country music their
[ __ ] are dogs
and then the rap music the [ __ ] are
you know or women
in rap they say whips yeah country music
they say trucks
yeah it's very similar music it's a lot
of the same stuff but ones for whites
once were
the others yeah one's for everybody else
yes and the chinese let's be honest the
chinese are the new blacks dude
you know you think oh yeah why is that
oh there's
so many of everything dude yeah so many
kid they don't you know they're you know
a lot of dangerous activity
um some sports they do some sports okay
you seen that bicycling guy in the world
record book no bro yeah it's like him
and like 70 of his cousins on one bike
dude trying to go somewhere
here's the only thing why rap music wins
this because
if you're at a party and let's say
you're trying to get loose yeah you put
on that shania twain it shuts that [ __ ]
down no one's have no one's drinking
that no one's getting their dick and
titties out to that
you put on some kanye some yeezy
some little pump and [ __ ] the tits
are out bro little pump killed himself
bro okay
no you're thinking of uh uh kurt cobain
oh am i really no
no i'm not yeah you are well he did kill
himself but i'm thinking of a little
parkinson's or whatever the new guy is
named
little park it's everything's little
yeah little wayne little pump little
truancy are any of these [ __ ] kids
going to school that's what i wanted to
know a little home school
yeah where's that dude a little
homeschooler where's that amish white
rapper
a little homeschooled little dicky yeah
oh a little dicky isn't that bad i heard
no i love little dicky um but uh he's
confusing white rappers confusing no but
dude
sing country i don't know if you've ever
been alive or not but if you have
then there was a good time in your life
where a country song came on
and you read it at a dance and that's
when you got to do that slow dance you
know
are you talking uh dick to butt oh no
front to front dude oh no
no we weren't allowed to do slow dances
dick
that's what we did at my school and your
hands had to be on like up here and you
had to
lower your hands bro dude that wasn't a
school bro that was a
special ed meet-up if you were
slow dancing with your hands over
somebody's shoulders
dick to butt yeah bro until we did it
shout out to virginia court
shout out to the virginia court tigers
yeah shout out to mr samularo my first
crush
yeah we're talking about the virginia
court system obviously
that sounds like some prison reform
dancing i'm gonna stand strong with
country music man it'll be here
rap is running out of dude all these
rappers now they're all wealthy kids of
other rappers they're not nobody's even
from anywhere
i'm i'm with you on this i think
country's gonna stick around a lot
longer because in rap especially the
culture like little pump all these
people they're into them drugs tell me
about them drugs you ever seen and i
love uh
post malone that dude yeah any day
yeah you need to hook him up with your
uh team oh i'll get him a 70 ounce
therapy from the [ __ ]
i'm with you though country music
country music right on
next one this is a good one from j-rod
j-rod is a man or woman i think we'll
find out we have it's definitely girls
really submit stuff
real [ __ ] fest
are you taking and pissing the tortoise
style are you taking a piss with your
right
leg begin
hell yeah was it the greatest video
submission of all time
shout out to that dude wow we i think we
yeah i used to least land from that guy
i thought
i think you owe that guy money i'm sure
from back in the day i was talking about
old thiel you turned a new leaf now
oh get your drugs out of his face bro
yeah he had that
hog on him boy you see that pork sausage
that wasn't turkey bro hell no
that's that's that's that's that's
that's that's that's their brother
that's that farmer john ham
brother dude this one's easy for me i
don't like the urinals like i was just
at the mall i don't like the urinals
because you can see everyone's
[ __ ] up too you know what i'm saying you
can peep and see everyone's dick i think
i liked a little bit of privacy
and we've talked about this before if
you look at other parts of people's
bodies you don't see their dick
you know like if you look at somebody's
eyes or you know their face their
chin um shoulders legs
feet hands elbows biceps
back small on the back teeth there's way
more places to look so if you're looking
at people's dicks you're gonna see them
but you can't make eye contact bro
yeah you shouldn't be because you're all
peeing together yeah but yes
straight forward like a goddamn psycho i
like to see what's going on
i'm also i'm i think it's the movie true
lies like too bad guys and come behind
me so i'm looking at the reflection and
the little metal
part coming off i'm worried someone's
gonna attack me
so what i like to do i like to go in the
in the in the with the privacy one i
like to just
show them i got that super soaker and i
[ __ ] pump
into that thing you guys really fast and
hard hard like a super soaker i like
i like i want everyone to know i'm
bringing that [ __ ] fear not though
i hate the guy that does that he goes in
there and he pees as
fast and as hard as he can yeah four
seconds that's me bro
do you take your time oh dude i will
piss for two and a half
minutes brother i'll make a plant in the
hallway jealous brother
oh i drip all day
they're like who is that guy you know
what hydration
i heard one guy say man is that filtered
beautiful
that fiji one i'll say this a urinal
no thank you okay first of all it's like
a gang bang
on a drain it's like oh can this drain
all this yes
it's a lot going on in there and then
there's always that [ __ ] who writes
on the wall
yeah like with the phone numbers there's
graffiti on the wall
there's always something nasty on there
but i like to go in and out bro
because you want to be there for too
long because homeboy next year's [ __ ]
dropping osama bin laden just
yeah real hair so i could get out bro
yeah yeah i mean i don't mind being in a
bathroom for a long time
so i guess you have to be you know we're
kind of from different sides of the
track when it comes to
raised in there i got a question for
brendan when you're peeing in the stall
are you lifting up the toilet seat or
are you leaving piss on the seat
for the next person to sit down in
because i've rousted two people in our
old building for doing that dude case by
case
case by case if i'm at if i'm at the gas
station
get the [ __ ] out of my face wipe it down
nah man
nah man if it's at a nice place like i'm
at the the grove or something i know
it's a nice
bathroom some dude's been holding that
[ __ ] in all day and he's after me i'll
lift that seat
case by case yeah well that's a good
call i respect the case by case on the
uh
on the toilet seat now i had an issue
one time i was trying to get um
a little bit of gas and they uh
and so i went into the urinal and it was
one of those you know they had a couple
urinals in there you know it was like a
family style
and in the bathroom i mean and while i
was in there some nut case came in there
you know some deviant
and it was a hitchhiker i think or some
guy that just you know wasn't going
you know didn't care where he was going
yeah he came in there
got feces out of his body right rubs it
on the door and
everywhere to get out so now i'm
trapped into this [ __ ] doo-doo
spackled us into the room right
wow so now [ __ ] gingerbread house oh
dude yeah yeah
yeah so now i'm caulked into the room
bro they had to bust
out the window and get us out through
there bro damn
bro this yeah trauma bro oh man it was
just
ah the [ __ ] viper just attacked a [ __ ]
viper
it's case by case for me so it's case by
case but look i'm i'm not afraid to be
at a urinal
if some of the guys there are nice guys
i don't like pissing around mean guys
or if the other thing too about that
privacy of the
of the big bowl sometimes you want to
play a game
someone will come in there with horrible
diarrhea and spray the sides and now you
can knock that down with your pee
knock it down i caught it's like it's
kind of like an atari video game
spaceship with your
piss dude everyone's gonna be so weird
or not you know what urinals i will
never
well look i cannot believe i'm talking
to a man who
urinates on top of other dudes dookie
dude sometimes that happens it's case by
case bro
you haven't been on the road enough then
you're in a road i have bro
you haven't i've pissed on a lot of
things in my life okay
abyss indoors outdoors upstairs off
buildings moving vehicles dude
i pissed i tried to uh pissed on myself
in a jet once
sure but i've never urinated on top of
another man's skull
then you ain't living brother well what
else we got i'm glad to be dead
all right last one for a debate club
hopefully you guys know teenage mutant
ninja turtles this is this is from chase
hopefully the [ __ ] hopefully you have
anything i mean i have my master's green
teenage mutant ninja turtles yeah
haven't you seen brennan's bed sheets
come on bro yeah good one theo
oh he looks like oh is that
chase quinby what's up king of the sting
it's mailman chase not mailman chase
cause i'm on the job and i don't want to
get fired i'm not telling you exactly
where
calling in for the debate club i don't
have any skin in this game i really
don't care about this
but bebop are rocksteady never watch the
show
look at his neck piece he's got that uh
touch me
oh they get little helpers this time of
year to help him out yeah you can't be
touching the boxes
um bebop and rock study thank you for
the submission brother and thank you for
your service to america dude
um shout out to your uh teenage ninja
turtle scarf too
yeah dude mail is like i mean they're
like the military basically you try to
deliver mail to somebody's house these
days they'll [ __ ] shoot you oh dude
you gotta have your [ __ ] together dude
you walk up to somebody's yard with a
couple of [ __ ] letters bro
you're getting gunned down yeah they're
brave man very brave dude
and this is a teenage mutant ninja
turtle fan because bebop and rock study
not your typical question about teenage
mutant ninja turtles i grew up on this i
know you grew up without a tv you just
got drawings
but for me this was a big deal man bebop
and rock study
and are they both male 1 yeah they're
both male although the pig looks like
he's down for either or
he looks like a transgender kind of uh
hero well i wouldn't say that i think
bebop looks a little lesbian for
sure like a healthy lesbian kind of
really yeah he looks transgender to me
or a raiders fan
might be an a type you know what i'm
saying that's true pansexual
i think he looks like theo yeah i could
see that too i can see that same nose
underbite you have another bite oh you
do i see it from here yeah yeah
i think i do look like that bulldog yeah
you do you
do sir i looked over here like this
you look like a [ __ ] you look like
bubble gum you look like bubble gum if
you got sammy sosa's lotion
bro you look horrible i look horrible
yeah you look like a community college
mascot dude
you look like a child bro i look like a
child yeah
which your shirt says america's game all
right what game
america's getting there bro teamwork all
right friendship you idiot all right
you look like ron white's gay sister all
right
whatever and her name is sandra okay and
they call her sandy shout out to ron
white's sister if you have this one
true story i got a blow job from jared
fogle's sister one time when i was in
college
the subway chick she hot she's
you know she's a night she's exciting
you know that means
no whatever exciting like a six foot
[ __ ] or six inch meatball sub
or exciting like a turkey sub i mean
i think she was cool did you give her
the foot long uh i gave her as much as i
had it wasn't
the same was it yeah yeah i gave her
that four inch round
they gave her the cookie on the side
gave me the cookie on the side oh yeah
but those are the good old days man dude
i'm not suing her he's in prison is he
yeah
you didn't hear about this oh she
probably didn't tell you
yeah he touched a bunch of kids
theo yeah bro god
were you one of them no no no i wasn't i
was i think a legal adult
you know but man there's a defendant
it's hard though
you know i'm not defending him yeah yeah
you're acting like you everyone knows
jared from subway's a total [ __ ]
creep i i haven't had subway in forever
because of that
i can't buy your meatball sub i know
you're sucking kids off on the side
everyone knows this they did have those
small milks there you could get right
think about all the kids [ __ ] they had
and he would shut the [ __ ] up about
eating
six inch subs and losing all this weight
shut the [ __ ] up man
it worked for him though didn't it yeah
you get defensive because you
you still communicate with his sister no
we've never we communicated briefly one
night
that was it i can't believe he did all
that though did the kids say he did it
hold on the kids yeah the army of kids
that he molested
yeah they all came out and said he did
he's in prison bro he put the weight
back on
because he now he's eating at the
commissary put on the male bees yeah
he's about three hundo again that's
crazy someone sent me a quiz knows dude
that's why i'm eating quiznos man
toasted sausage oh toast that [ __ ] up i
want you to just
bake the molestability right now [ __ ]
yeah just cook the sin right out of my
body praise god
dude subway or quiznos there's one for
you quiznos
quiz post that [ __ ] bro yeah how about
feed your kids
yeah and let them just you know not get
not meet a man
you know i don't know how we got on just
lunch quiznos
so between bebop and rocksteady we
picked quiznos yeah that was
that was a great debate club all right
it's time for king it or sting it
uh number one coming from amanda
hatfield oh here's a lady
hey guys my name is amanda i'm
originally from canada but now i live
just outside of chicago
wow i love the new podcast they're both
awesome
my question for you is about face
tattoos
with artists like post malone etc
getting them
they're becoming more and more popular
with just regular people yep
yeah what do you think inmates face
tattoos king it or sting it yeah
everyone who doesn't want to think
you guys bye what's up girl love you
love them
i love all of you yes and i don't care i
don't see just one part of someone like
this
does jared from subway neanderthal
um face tattoos terrible idea unless
you're famous as
[ __ ] and you don't need another job do
not get face tattoos look at this dude
that's sick six nine bro yeah and he's
in jail now for crimes
for he's probably gonna be in there for
a long long time alleged also
uh he's screwed dude he's the he's a
dominican bobby schmurder bro
yeah you're right but let me say this i
think face tattoos are good
in a few instances give me something
okay
one you short-term memory loss
or long-term you can keep just [ __ ]
need to know information at the ready
you know
it depends what you put on your face
yeah it does you don't put like yeah
directions to a [ __ ] you know arcade
you put like
things that you know i'm allergic to
sesame seed oil or something like that
all right like need to know information
face tattoos
um i think anything that is like uh
you know a seasonal kind of thing like
happy you know
new year happy black history month happy
halloween
you know you should you think they
should put that on their face and then
cover it up for the rest of the time
wear sunglasses or something
yeah kind of dope so then they're only
cool one month out of the year though
yeah face tattoos i'm trying to argue
for it and it's not going
happening bro come on think about when
you get older everyone's face gets
droopy yours has already started not a
big deal
everyone's different everyone's
different
that's because it's a little droopy but
think about it you get a face tattoo
and they just start to change your face
starts to melt and come off you know
what i'm saying
no it doesn't dude yeah if your parents
look like [ __ ] it does pro who told you
your face isn't
falling a little bit dude no my face is
gravity bro
doing well and i respond well to gravity
you respond well to botox
wow i'll get whatever man i will too
i'll say this though
if you have a face tattoo then i think
you need to already be
probably married or you know you need to
be
you need at least a million in the bank
to get a face tattoo yeah
because you ain't gonna work at a bank
sure as [ __ ] not gonna work at
blockbuster
you can do any of that stuff yeah and
people are gonna want to
judge you judge you but i think we're at
the end of the line with our face i
don't think we're even gonna use our
this is the you know people are getting
face tattoos people are you know getting
you know part of their body chiseled
into like a mount rushmore chiseled in
their leg you know
people are getting unique things this is
the end of the actual use of our skin
like
in the future there will be another
layer that we will wear
to better protect ourselves it's still
insane that we leave our skin
just at the behoove of the elements all
the time bro
you know what i'm saying you start
wearing a mask yeah everyone is
really yeah some ugly people hope
nelly's friends
nellie's friends started it nelly
nelly's friend
started it yeah that dude one guy with
the mask the guy that was in a fire
murphy lee
what's his name what happened to him
he's a fireman didn't go well
what happened to that dude why did he
always wear a mask he didn't want people
to see his real [ __ ]
no he just had a style or he caught a
case
you know what i'm saying so he left the
mask on so no one could figure out what
he oh
dude he's a copycat he's doing phantom
of the opera
look at him though nelly and murphy lee
had a beef it said
oh really why because he wouldn't take
the [ __ ] mask off
probably that's family opera that [ __ ]
ain't original
but i agree having a friend with a mask
on at a certain point but it's the
future i'm telling you next is a mask so
people are going to be
that's ugly people hope so do i see how
you'd want that but it's not going that
direction but it's changing man
chin and nick would you guys wear a mask
we need someone with a mask in the group
i'll wear a mask i'll be the mask yeah
really right there one [ __ ] dude you
had to ask him
one time and now he has a mask dude he's
in yeah all right
yeah see how easy it was i got my st
lunatics mixed up uh
murphy lee didn't wear a mask it was one
of them though
all right well [ __ ] face that dudes i i
think they're a bad idea
i think they are just a sign of the
times people don't need their faces
anymore it's almost over
it's more about like your electronic
profile we're just we're devolving man
name the hottest person with a face
tattoo only ugly people get face tats
no kat von d kat von whatever dude she's
a tattoo artist but still just tattoos
on her
anus [ __ ] up you know she's hot kat
von d
she's pretty hot but she she's that she
doesn't count she's a tattoo artist
like she they all that's all she name
another person that's not involved in
the tattoo game great reference though
channel give me that
great reference you tried [ __ ] me you
tried [ __ ] me but tattoo artists they're
out of it because they get tattoos on
their eyeballs
who kayla who's that
uh
oh kyrie irving she's a homie hopper
yeah she seems like that maybe she can
hop on this homie
well she also looks like frida kyle's
young you know
young son um okay i'm not a lot of hot
people with face tattoos is the point
there's a few
okay what about this though does it if
you're already attractive
yeah can you do whatever you want wow to
a certain extent because you get it
looks kind of sexy right right
like if you're already attractive can
you just do what it is you know
and it's gonna look dope yeah a busted
person gets his face tattooed yeah
he's going to [ __ ] jail you know what
i'm saying like little wayne his entire
face is tattooed but we have no idea
right you know that his entire face is
covered in tattoos
yeah what just funny i don't know it
just
yeah well it wasn't funny and
yeah i was being real it was really i
was being real i saw him last night in
the american music me too
yeah he didn't know what was going on
yeah looks like he just yeah i don't
know that's what happens when you face
that dude if you go
crazy well you got to go all in whatever
you're doing
you know if you're a lumberjack and you
get a you know a slice of wood on your
cheek or something you got to go all in
here's the thing
face tattoo or neck tattoo neck tattoo
screams i've made
bad choices in my life yes tattoo goes
i'm hip
i'm trying to be cool you know but neck
tattoo says there's one
bad choice i'm not gonna make and that's
a face that too
yeah don't [ __ ] don't [ __ ] touch
me dude it sounds like we're stupid
are you recording when he touches me
like that of course it hurts
it hurts all right next one comes from
zach
barrett zack baird is that french
dick out of my friend what's up man oh
[ __ ]
you big fans here from west palm beach
florida
got a question for you guys florida in
general
hear a lot about it in the news a lot of
negativity
you see this out here florida can't get
her sting it
what's that hitter man oh get that
hitter mama you heard her in the
bathroom
she had that theovon face i don't know
if you saw that or not yeah
no it's good for you guys dude uh yeah
well my nose
looks like your whole body dude this is
how small in the wrong nose looks like a
potato
well half my family it was irish farmers
dude
dude i'm not saying it's a bad thing i
don't really take offense okay i'm not
taking
a face all right all right cool okay you
look like a lady
that's trying to grow a beard you know
transgender he's taking sean hormones
and
ears starting to come out no you're like
a lady that's too cheap to get the
hormones you're not trying to fight
he's just growing it just just a few
sharecropping yourself at the house dude
yeah you look like you bought the
italian [ __ ] transgender starter
you look like the mascot for florida
just a [ __ ] show
like florida foot their oceans they have
no waves you can't [ __ ] surf there
it's just a [ __ ] bunch of [ __ ] going
on in florida miami's all right
miami's okay i agree with that he's
overrated i'll say this to this couple
that i will be
at the west palm beach improv april 26th
and 27th i do want to say that
but outside of that look man uh i think
florida is good man florida is a great
place to hide from the government
florida's a great place to launder money
a great place to
slip away to cuba it's kind of like the
appendix of
of of america it's like do we need it
not really
yeah could we get it removed yeah yeah
like if they just if it just floated
away like yeah whatever yeah who would
go get it
nobody yeah then then they're an island
yeah
now that i don't mind it i don't i don't
hate
florida orlando beautiful women out
there
yeah there's some beautiful women a lot
of them are sex trafficked
you're not there and a lot of them not
their type you're not their type
really yeah that's why you don't like it
no that's not true yeah that's why i
don't like
really yeah cause you don't tan well
your haircut's all weird they're very
sexy and and ethnic down there you just
don't fit in
dude you look like a bouncer at an
arcade bro okay
yeah a dope bouncer at the miami arcade
yeah that's slinging
dick yeah to that protects mortal kombat
okay yeah
good luck step in line at mortal kombat
whatever on my watch
brendan uh we lost the air hockey puck
again we need you to uh help out over
here
okay tighten up dude you definitely look
like a [ __ ] dude that works at foot
locker
you look like every white dude that
works at foot locker
get your whistle brendan get your
whistle for them get your
they don't wear whistles anymore well
they took the ball out of it they don't
work do they
so sad who carries a limp whistle around
[Music]
why'd they make them carry whistles dude
you were a couple bad episodes from
[ __ ]
getting hired back in the [ __ ] black
and white stripes bro
and i'm not talking about pretending
you're a zebra at kids birthday parties
i'm talking toys you look like the
mascot for toys r us
just a [ __ ] bummer you're a bummer
dude yeah that was funny
oh [ __ ] florida though i love florida
and i will like i said i'll see you guys
april 26th and 27th at the west palm
beach improv
so one kings one stings the next one
from shayna plank
what up theo and brendan my name's
shayna it's king it or sing it
man purses i work at starbucks and i see
these suspect dudes walking up and all
prissy like in these man purses and i
question it what y'all think
though thank you for uh your i mean
starbucks is basically
it is the front lines of america these
days i mean they are they are basically
uh
service workers they've taken over
starbucks is
everywhere well they deal with
everybody's attitude first thing in the
morning
like hey i'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] i know
why don't i order something
i know yeah then they get mad it takes
too long and [ __ ] yeah
and here is a beautiful young lady who's
been up since
midnight she woke up at yeah 3 a.m
to serve your stupid coffee yeah just
frappuccino
no whip light soy extra caramel
macchiato yeah
um i'm leaving my wife just give me
something that tastes like that
you know get me some [ __ ] give me
some [ __ ]
i'm an angry woman that uh spent my
whole life trying to earn money and
doesn't have any kids now can i have
that
a medium it's called a frappuccino yeah
you mean a milkshake [ __ ] yeah you know
what frappuccino is a
milkshake where i come from is it yeah
you [ __ ] idiots
a frappuccino is a milkshake bro you
seem like
every [ __ ] dude that's definitely
hitting on girls we'll call them girls
even though they're barely legal at a
lot of uh
food courts you know you seem like the
kind of dude that tries to [ __ ] chicks
at a food
that hangs out by panda express not buy
it but definitely
and the lemonade stand you look like you
work at orange julius yeah bro
that's the only guy yeah that's fine
dude meeting all the chicks
and squeezing them squeezing them
um what the overall oh starbucks yeah
oh man
man purses well your boy joe rogan has
one uh different so this is different
and i'll defend joe here
because a fanny pack that [ __ ]
uses it as because it's functional he
has all that [ __ ] in there
he's always he's been on that for since
the jump dude and now gucci came out
with them
and kids want to wear them over their
shoulders and do all that
[ __ ] that's the [ __ ] that's frowned
upon but i i do
support a fanny pack they make a lot of
sense i don't like [ __ ] in my pockets
rogan has all he had the mayan calendar
in his one time like he has a
lot of wild stuff crystal ball mine
calendar
um he had a bow and arrow in there yeah
he had the uh
tropic of cancer in there one time like
definitely
carrying some unique things around so it
makes sense for him it makes sense for
some men who are active men now you're
talking about these little patsies
yeah you know these little fellas up
there living in yeezys on
oh yeah yeezy one of them has an easy
neck brace because he's in some fake
[ __ ] lawsuit
um because he got dick whipped over at
the foot lock dick
has an off-white mouthpiece in and [ __ ]
[ __ ] them dude yeah he has a service
mouse in it
[ __ ] that dude you know what i'm saying
yeah i think it depends i think look no
matter what they're wearing you look
them in the eyes young lady and you know
if they're a real man or not
you know especially based off the drink
they order yeah what do you order when
you go to starbucks when i go to
starbucks and get black coffee dude
extra black
don't do it don't [ __ ] touch me dude
stupid ass
don't look at me next one dude [ __ ]
say the next one i think you guys should
end each segment by saying king or sting
okay yeah just
uh
yeah all right the last one of the day
for king interesting it is
ryan williams oh ryan williams the
musician what's up to you i'm pregnant
oh willie here i'm in brisbane with my
girlfriend having a weekend away
and i was just wondering what do you
think about riding a scooter wow i've
seen brennan on a scooter sometimes so
i want to know do you king it or do you
sting it is a scooter your girlfriend
bruh
yeah because i was oh king your
girlfriend
i was getting your boy he's underage you
can see he's in high school
she's not bro that is a grown woman
she's a history teacher
okay sure that's going to hold up in
court um
well young man i'd like to say this i'm
glad you guys are enjoying your summer
vacation
and it looks like you and your young
girlfriend are having a nice time
um scooters yeah let's talk to [ __ ]
this bad boy over here oh i'm sorry
scooters aren't
bad enough for you my my bad what should
i be
on a harley should i find a [ __ ]
harley first of all
that's a regular scooter that's not one
of the the birds or something like that
when i come into the new town i need to
scoot around town i jump on a bird or i
jump on one of those [ __ ] things from
time to time dude
now nothing dries up girls mouths and uh
bodies like when seeing a grown man on a
scooter
why not just let a big giant gay dude
carry you around on his back right
dude they're tough to find they're
always busy they're always busy
i have that app um and yeah
yeah talk about gay jack they're not
easy in every town bro like in utah
find gay jack yeah they're busy that's
true of them low-key you really
yeah you almost need to shovel to really
find a good gay around there
but i'll say this man that you got that
on that
gucci sack right there and that deal
you're wearing yeah bro i keep uh
electrolytes in there coconuts extra t
cells you need to [ __ ] tighten up
yeah bro
carrots yeah ear hooks books for you to
read
yeah i'll say this i would rather run
out of gas and just sit in my car than
be seen
[Laughter]
easily yeah that's because that's cause
you you you don't want to look any
gay you don't want that bro i'd rather
let the lord just
fill my tank then uh they
jump on that bird oh my god you do feel
weird on them but have you ever been on
it you've
had the wind blow in your face and blow
that that's not the wind bro that tail
you got back there in the wind you've
never had that bro yeah you need
if you experience that then come holler
at me it's that queso whip baby
but i i'm gonna go ahead and uh
surprisingly i'm gonna
i'm gonna sting scooters
yeah you know why because uh where we
live in our next woods they're
everywhere now yep and it's kind of
taking over the neighborhood like ants
and kids go in and out of my ceiling kid
get hit by a car on one oh i've seen a
couple of straight up
adults use them and get grilled
it's hilarious and they're always
carrying groceries and they always just
lay there until the ambulance comes
get up get out quit faking it dude
putting the nba what are you foreigner
in the nba equipment flop
if you get hit by a car at less than 30
miles an hour get the [ __ ] down get the
[ __ ] up bring your stupid groceries and
get going
yeah yeah don't pick up your eggs if
they're all broken i get that [ __ ]
but collect the [ __ ] onions and keep
it hoofing the courts are backed up
okay we have bigger problems yeah
because in traffic
yeah i'm voting no one [ __ ] scooters
yeah saying that
dang it all right guys that does it for
kingdom sting it
uh it's time for the new segment that's
sweeping the nation
flaunt my aunt oh yeah all the kids are
talking about flop my own
are they the kids it's the rage online
is it really the rage
what happened people's aunts getting
[ __ ] getting thirsty
it blow me up oh [ __ ] blow me up
oh man no foreign they call her
yeah the staple honey she [ __ ]
slipped in my dms did
all right what do we got uh and i will
say when you submit these to the dropbox
title the image with who it is in your
family your uncle some of these were
unclear and we couldn't use them and
they were good
here's the first one from will terrell
he sent in his aunt
zoom in bro
all right all right all right clearly
works at a skate shop
uh why do you say that bro what do you
mean bro
look at her with them wheels that ain't
your normal skateboard
she's obviously a uh [ __ ] surf and
shop
fan here first of all i think she has
very nice let's look at her face can we
please
okay somebody's about to get fired um i
think she has a nice
kind of like she looks harmless
oh she looks pissed off like someone
[ __ ] up her skateboard no i think she
has that covert kind of like librarian
but
risky you know i can like encyclopedia
brown my ass
you know like she has that sort of like
wish oh
come fall through my closet you know
narnia i'll be your ass
it's like andy richter she looks like
andy from conan andy richter who uh
yeah no she looks like a lean sexier
andy richter i could see that
is that really someone's aunt what's her
name we do not have her name yeah they
gotta start saying the names if they can
can't have the full name and she said
first name i'll say this
she's at a hardware store so that's
pretty simple fixing her goddamn
skateboard that's why she's there she
had to skate her ass there
and her wheel fell off or some [ __ ] and
she's obviously handy let's see that's
super handy
she also looks like she doesn't need a
man at all she's got some
there's no rings hats on her you think
oh she's got some real
ptedodactyls on her boy i'd let one of
those swoop into my [ __ ] mouth
god i wouldn't i probably couldn't box
them out really yeah i'd box them out
like dennis rodman oh she got them
to talk to doc pterodactyls dude and i'd
let one of those things fly down my
throat boy i'm gonna say this
i'm gonna say this if you and her got in
a fight she would give you all
you could handle oh definitely oh you'd
be a scrap well
like round around i'd have to look at
the judges but god it's close
oh i wouldn't stay on my feet i ground
and pound with her bro you know what i'm
saying i take it straight to the [ __ ]
ground bro
can we get her again i want to see a
little bit more of that board can we
just see that
what's that board say yeah can we just
there we go see she's she
she she's misindependent she doesn't
need a man [ __ ] skated there
fixed her board matched her watch with
the skateboard she has a
fitbit she has those outdoor pants on
like this she ain't staying indoors
don't say any bahamas yeah she's going
to be around the neighborhood
yeah she's looking for a dude she'll
give a [ __ ] about your dick she does
have on a men's t-shirt though
that's what i'm saying she's giving off
that vibe yeah
she's giving off that vibe oh you know
what she might be the captain of like
the skateboard club in the neighborhood
i'll meet a man or i'll meet a woman and
i'll decide which one i'm gonna be in
the relationship whoever's nicer
yeah whoever's down to skate with me
that's straight up freelance janet right
there boy
she makes her own choices goes with the
win you talking about free spirit janet
all right what else we got let's see
another flaunt
all right the next one from zara barrett
sent in there what we assumed to be
uncle or grandpa let me see this uncle
oh damn bro where's this dude you
talking about papa murphy
has this guy been hiding in the closet
is this a holocaust survivor
who is this dude talk about the monopoly
man before he went bald
look i mean did they give somebody been
keeping their grandfather in a
uh in a box yeah what is going on
did someone freeze their grandpa he just
got out
like austin power style look how happy
this
is in pajamas on the bottom is this
grand papa john this dude is
90 years old and hella
i don't know healthy as [ __ ] he looks
like he's been
kept in that closet for the last 50
years got out
he's happy a little bright for his eyes
until you've seen the sunlight in quite
some time
and you can see he looks like he makes
the meanest pasta dish on the planet oh
he looks like he could
yeah oh he could cough up a damling you
know
just a sweet surprise tony yeah he looks
like he makes the meanest lasagna oh
he'll [ __ ] spit in a marsala right
into your [ __ ] mouth
mr journal baby i don't know who that is
mr journal he does have liver spots so
he is getting older i will say that he
has a casio
watch so it's time for him to [ __ ]
meet the lord
hey bro what the [ __ ]
dude is not time for meet the lord he's
seen some
[ __ ] in his day though i agree he saw
the first plane he saw
all sorts of [ __ ] dude he was obviously
rescued from
who knows where i mean somebody's been
keeping this man behind
boarded walls i agree look at the carpet
shady but then look is there a hole in
the wall back there
and why is he on the ground for this
picture why was someone like papa
papa let me get a picture while you're
on the ground putting this [ __ ]
puzzle together yeah is this actually a
cry for help and not just a picture
somebody submitted did you guys get this
off the back pages is this someone's
grandpa who needs help because me and
theo ain't the ones
we don't have time to help them swm baby
you feel me
what magazine is he reading that's a
phone that's a phone book
it's obviously someone looking for help
can we just admit you're right
you're right that grandpa needs help
yeah so wrong place wrong time
wrong show yeah um yeah you might want
to email a picture into 911.com
because i don't know if we can help what
else you got shout out to papa jigeno
all right yeah let's see some aunts
let's see some freaking hot aunts
man all right who is that this is uh
from james h cousin jasmine
oh how are you gonna go from papa de
journo to this
smoke show and first of all theo
i know you have some sort of weird
problem where you can't look at women
right now because
autism you idiot so put your
boner away for a second because she is
fine that's somebody's aunt
is it really that's somebody's aunt bro
with them d
s [ __ ] l's what is that
dick sucking lips bro really now get
your boner out my face
what yeah i know what's going on you get
all quiet and i see the blood
leave your [ __ ] face and it feels
that little cocky
that's cause i'm a natural man first of
all you delinquent that's cause you
haven't seen this
seven years because your parole officer
won't let you that's how people's bodies
work you cook
okay first of all
who's i will say this i
would certainly probably call her
and talk to her and i would meet her
somewhere
and do you know all talk about whatever
she wants to talk about and listen
uh you care you think she's that hot
you'd listen oh i would talk and listen
i would let her order a frappuccino from
starbucks and not criticize her
dude i would build a starbucks somewhere
near
my neck dude i would let her drive the
[ __ ] scooter while i'm on the back
like a [ __ ] with my boner
ramming into her ass oh what
uh i would let her probably beat me with
a 2x4
until i came out of my eye sockets oh
wow bro
but no she seems like a nice lady i
wonder how old she is now
do we know if she's over 18 or we are
kellyanne bro
she's over eight definitely over 18.
okay you know your [ __ ]
yeah and she's an adult and she seemed
like a nice
person dude but she's indoors she's like
though
like data from star trek like why is she
like this she's indoor she could be
talking into her hand
oh you know what she might have a
bluetooth yeah she could have a
bluetooth
now she also looks like she definitely
is
probably gonna have a kid with a brother
pretty soon
i didn't want to say it but she looks
like she likes all the dicks
right you don't wear lipstick like that
with a bra and not suck dick
monday tuesday wednesday thursday friday
saturday sunday recuperate well i wasn't
gonna say any of that
i was gonna say she looks like she
wouldn't mind meeting a decent black man
locally somewhere or maybe from like a
decent college like um
clemson tulane something georgia yeah
georgia southern lipscomb florida
international
university yeah yeah yeah every
university uh it's
devry you're an idiot but i'll say this
she seems like a nice lady she seemed
like she would have a beautiful
mixed child you know and she could
probably be our next uh
she could be our mascot senator you're
out john martino new mascot
yeah you're out guys
because this smoke shows in wow she does
seem like a cool person though
yeah where is she she's indoors in the
picture she's indoors
she could live anywhere she looks like
she has roommates
okay let's take one more man and then i
got to get out of here all right we got
another aunt
from cody tevis
[Music]
this is the [ __ ] cruise ship you're
on there what's going on here punt my
gun you see that dude straight up
that dude
there's jared from subway oh that guy is
a straight up
polar bear right there a shade polar
bear huh
he's got that belly hair that evenly
spaced though i like that
sexy a lot of guys just get the happy
trail he has a happy troll but evenly
spaced out
i think he's shaving it you know no yeah
i think i don't think it grew in like
that
uh let's focus on the ant here for a hot
second i'll see that so is that her is
that an aunt
an uncle or is that some dude it looks
like this dude photobombed this and is
forcing her to take this picture if you
look at his hand also
why is he throwing up the shocker yeah
good call make it
easy and that's clearly in jersey shore
that's not california i recognize that
beach from anywhere
yeah it could be jersey she definitely
has kind of like that uh
you know like she would um she'd
accepted blood donation from brett
michael's type of vibe
oh yeah she looks like she's from raqqa
love oh yeah and she either has a
mixed drink with her or a drug test that
she's about to go turn in somewhere yeah
you ain't lying i can't tell what's in
that cup
she looks like a just a journeyman for
ac dc
yeah she just rocked out to that [ __ ] a
little too hard but she seems like a
cool lady she's probably a nurse she
probably looks like she's caring she has
a nice smile
you think nurse she has gone glasses she
looks like a little bit like captain lou
albano
if he had stage four cancer as well
but young what do you think the guy does
on the left besides eat everything
god damn what bro
he seems like a good guy paul
i'm not saying he's not nice i'm just
saying clearly he likes food there ain't
nothing wrong with that that's bubba
sparks you
delighted so bub sparks don't rap though
lovely
oh that was a jmi i bet you guys were
pounding that because you thought you
had one huh
bubba you know brian counts in that
video is he really you're
lying i promise wow i know i got to see
that man and he he how did he not open
up
a spark plug shop after that called
bubba or an energy drink called the
sparks
yeah bad name for an energy drink sparks
that's an actual energy drink you idiot
is it really yeah bro
four loko killed a lot of people dude
those are illegal
yeah it's like a gang it's like ms-13 in
a can yeah
i can't believe brian kellen's in this
well he's in a bubba sparked a video i
don't know if it's ugly
oh it's miss new booty oh wow i could
see him in that yeah
he seemed like a guy that would be in
that um that's it
boom flop my aunt shout out to all the
submissions man those were funny
a lot of beautiful aunts and and and and
uncles
and grandpas for that matter there were
some uh grandpas where's there
uh mr de journal oh yeah man and i hope
he's okay
i hope he's still alive and they find
that man yeah that is
very troubled very troubled man
it's tough out there for old people
though a lot of people are trying to you
know they don't know what to do with
their grandparents they're putting them
in homes they're hiding them in closets
keeping them in the car oh yeah in the
laundry room and one of my buddies
grandfather lives in his
laundry room i've heard of that he has
alzheimer's and he has everything just
keep him in the basement and throw video
games at him oh dude it's crazy
guys like you know he's got like
cerebral
hemorrhaging or something i don't know
all kinds of [ __ ] wild [ __ ] this guy
seems okay this guy seems healthy though
what that guy is laying on the floor
near an open closet door reading a phone
book or looking for help he's a broken
leg he definitely has a broken leg he
has one leg
his socks are super wrinkly what happens
when you get older man your ankles get
all baggy
yeah that's what i mean when you get
kidnapped dude this guy could be like 17
bro we don't know
bro kidnapping ages you so much like the
presidency
yeah it really does man you get
kidnapped at you know 15 or something
game over oh yeah by the time you're 23
you look like you're fifth are you
kidnapped
never not even close no i
they had a man that put us in his truck
one time but he was a
[Music]
uh semi-truck driver was just giving it
a ride home
no and then somebody came and caught him
and beat his ass dude he was
probably gonna be a pedophile but he's
close call we were just sitting not
available you homeschooled [ __ ] yeah in
edmonton
well freezing at edmonton thursday
friday saturday and then next
week next saturday my special yep san
diego baby
sprinkles it up that's a spreckels
theater and since that's already sold
out
a lot of you guys can come to irvine and
we will uh watch it on my phone
and um we can judge it and critique it
from far away let's do it man
you bet man uh you guys be good to
yourselves
this is the king of the sting king of
the sting
i'm the king bruh
you